do you get sad at the end of the year I
always get excited
I get that's not like an AI prompt you
get sad I'm excited
I am happy it's like there's an AI
generator
but it sounds like a human way of asking
it what was the human way okay why would
you ask are you sad by the way I'm happy
okay what is the mindset no my mind says
I always get excited at the end of the
year because it's like it's it's like
turning over a new Leaf why would
he be sad well God was saying this is
like oh it's the end of the year I'm a
bit sad and it's like sounding sad I'm
like oh do you get sad
um I don't get sad I get I get like
we're talking about sad guys I don't
know I need to make sure I'm doing okay
guys I'm doing okay I'm not sad by the
way we should just get AI to write this
[ __ ] party oh my God we did an
episode where an entire trash days
we should do an episode and then we
should do this uh well every everything
we talk about is an AI prompt sure yeah
okay that's that's an interesting first
episode first episode of 2023. this
trash taste episode has been AI
generated
what do you think of chicken feet how do
you feel about chicken feet it is
gelatinous and delicious nutritious yeah
so you were saying what what emotions do
you feel at the end of the year what
emotions do I feel uh yeah like a little
bit of excitement I think everyone's
always excited for the new year to
Starbucks like I don't know something
about
something by going into a new year right
the January February month it doesn't
you're still like you're still like
mourning the past year it always feels
like you know I was trying to find a
word to use but it doesn't feel like it
doesn't feel like the new year has like
it feels like the previous year version
two yeah yeah yeah yeah you still like
mentally you're still like turning over
to the new year yeah I guess because
there's no big like kind of like Earth
doesn't have this built-in program that
is like it is now reset yeah
it's like it's just kind of like well
next day in it yeah it's yeah it's that
it's that period where like especially
when you're in school and you had to
like you know write the the date on you
know your paper or whatever yeah it's
always just like oh okay January 2nd
2020 oh wait I'm in 2023 now
you know everyone had it everyone went
through that [ __ ] yeah I didn't find a
Nemo come out in 2008 or something I
feel so old just I just thought about
that sometimes were you thinking for
some reason whenever I think about when
Finding Nemo was released it makes me
feel old
because I can remember watching and
getting excited
yeah that's like [ __ ] amazing I had
traumatic nightmares of with [ __ ]
Bruce the shark dude he's hype that's
like that's what you mean if he was the
opposite are you a scary [ __ ] do you
ever just have this thing where there's
like certain shows or movies or
something else that in your mind feel
new even though they're like [ __ ] 10
years old now or something like that oh
like like of a recent memory yeah like
like for me like I have like so many
anime that for me like feel new came out
two years ago yeah gorilla gone feels
like came out two years ago it was like
15 or something years old I also feel
that with like League champions as well
I don't know if you feel this as well
yeah to me like a champion like for
example like azir feels new to me yeah
you know and it's just and it's just
like I I know he's [ __ ] decades old
now or something like that and it's
totally relate yeah you can relate right
Joey hashtag relatable [ __ ] Hanzo
means
[Music]
I know my references I don't know I
think um looking back at the year
um it's I don't really get sad to answer
your question I'm just going completely
off topic yeah sort of don't really get
sad I normally try to remember the
highlights and if something bad did
happen it's like okay well am I kind of
past that now yeah because I feel like
especially of recently you know like
with the whole [ __ ] Duma culture
especially among like you know just like
[ __ ] people you know this year was
horrible and I'm like okay yeah no the
world is definitely [ __ ] but I feel like
now it's like kind of the thing to just
be like [ __ ] pessimistic and negative
about [ __ ] even if it's like not
necessarily something that you should be
pessimistic about like you know it's
like having a forward like thinking or
being positive about something is like
seen as uncool now I mean I get it I I
get it I mean I don't know if I'm
British I get it because I feel like
we'll be doing that [ __ ] for thousands
of years I will admit that like there's
never been a time uh in like the past
like you know 40 50 60 years
um where it was
um as [ __ ] to be a young person like
like there was it's never been like in
terms of if you're just the average not
like talking about ours or whatever but
like if you were like an average person
who was like 15 16 yeah yeah
you're not looking great like a lot of
modern developed countries you know uh
it's getting a lot more top heavy with
age and then there's a lot of other
social issues going on yes of course
jobs don't pay as much as say rent and
buying a house is like impossible so no
I don't understand where a lot of the
the anxiety comes from in terms of being
pessimistic and it's hard to be like hey
no dude just be positive and it's like
well yeah a lot of people saying that
their lives are going good
um so I understand why they'd want to be
pessimistic but I do admit though that
there is definitely the feels like it's
almost like a competition about who can
be more yeah who can suffer more than me
but and you know and then they're saying
this from like their like [ __ ]
MacBook and yeah yeah like
it was such a [ __ ] year uh tweeted from
iPhone 14. yeah
I get it in a sense but yes no I get it
I get it too but you know it's I think
it's also important to it I think it's a
balance right yeah it's like you know
you don't want to be like taking the
[ __ ] happy pills and being like Oh
yeah you know just ignore everything bad
that happened and just link to next year
but you know I think it's important to
be like okay yeah some [ __ ] things
happen this year some good things happen
this year but you just kind of weigh it
out to see like you know which ones you
want to forget about which ones are
important which ones you want to learn
it just seems like no matter what
furries are always winning they just
always they somehow always have money
another good year review thing
everything always goes well for very I
don't know why they always have money
behind winning how do they they always
winning worries no matter what always
seem to have disposable income even when
it could be like the greatest of great
depressions and they'll still be
commissioning artists at premium rates
for porn I don't know how how do they do
this I feel that way towards them they
know how to budget
is two dollars on food five dollars on
like electricity you got like 100 on
Bill and two thousand dollars on like a
furry suit or whatever it's like those
memes where it's like you have ten
dollars to spend and then it'll be like
one dollar unlike this thing yeah you
know that the Twitter thing yeah it's
always like ten thousand points
sorry go ahead go ahead you know at
least they're happy yeah I mean like to
me like I I really like I really like
December as a month because there's a
lot of exciting things happening I agree
Christmas click forward too and I I love
that period before the new year so where
it's just it's just anarchies nobody
knows what's open what's going on are
you working no are you working no
everyone's not working you get to like
catch up with family and stuff like that
you get to hang out go on holidays and
then like January hits and you're like
when is the next time that something big
is happening and you look and you you
look at January and look at February and
normally the earliest something biggest
plan is like March you know and that's
when that's when to me like like I like
December but like the January February
month are like the hangover after like
the cool December month you know you
need that though I think it's important
to have a month where there's not that
much going on yeah especially in it like
our jobs as well we're always doing so
much I think it's good to have those
kind of months where everyone's kind of
resetting and getting ready and getting
plans ready
um because I've already made a lot of
plans for like March April next year but
I have made nothing for like January on
purpose yeah because nobody remembers
what happens in their January and
February you like it because it's like
what did we do in this January February
we went skiing we had a little boy ski
trip oh [ __ ] that was that that was this
year that was this year yeah it feels
like 10 years ago God I just realized I
skied for the first time this year yeah
[ __ ] twice you've been twice I've been
three times three times yeah yeah yeah
oh my God this guy I'm just I I
completely like just forgot that this is
this is my first this is my first year
of skiing that I ever experienced yeah
I'm gonna be completely out of touch but
because
we talked about like being excited for
the new year and like you know this
whole Duma culture I feel like that's
just been exasperated by
the corona years you know like two
pandemic years
three pandemic years if you think about
it because it started in early 2020
right yeah yeah exactly so we basically
had like three pandemic years where it's
just like you know we looked at the year
and we thought couldn't get any worse
than this got worse yeah they were like
couldn't get any worse than this still
remain the same and you're like okay
okay this is the Year this is going to
be the year it did feel like it was
never gonna end yeah and then finally
2022 here and I feel like this was the
year that we were kind of waiting for
you know this was the year where it kind
of feels like you're getting a bit of
normalcy is that a word yeah back in
your life and stuff like that and I feel
like you know it's this was a good year
I I would say this was just
from my personal perspective I would say
this was a good year but also you know
talking to a lot of my friends or
something like that it was better than
2021 but it's not hard most people had a
better year this year yeah you know
people want to see their family people
got to you know spend more time I don't
remember what I did in 2021. it's like
that year is a blur for me yeah it's
like I remember doing a shitload of
trash taste and like maybe seeing my
family once and then that was it because
I didn't leave Japan at all yeah at
least you guys left you died in 2021
yeah we did and that was [ __ ] that
was terrified yeah the thought the fact
that I I completely wiped out of my
memory but I stayed in that quarantine
yeah yeah like for like three days right
I was like if you'd asked me to do that
now I'd be like no but I think I was so
desperate to see my friends and family
yeah I was like [ __ ] it fine I'll I'll
stay in the stupid hotel for three days
yeah I didn't want to uh obviously no
yes no no no no one's been one night in
an apple let alone let alone three all
right it's the last resort just I was
just thinking of like the stress you let
you go through just to go through just
to go insane like the easiest kind of
travel routes you know yeah that was
that was it was like that was so
traveling was so stressful back then
yeah and now it's still not it wasn't
nearly as it's still not as seamless
yeah um you know if anyone's coming into
Japan or planning a trip to Japan you'll
know you have to you know even though
it's not a big deal the whole uh vaccine
passport and doing the whole stupid app
thing like it literally doesn't matter
because everyone's just turning up
anyway and they're just they're like
okay did you just do this show which of
action like it doesn't matter but it's
like Japan is like projecting stress
onto you to get in and it's making you
feel like do you have these 17 pieces of
essential paperwork it's like uh like
right now I'm flying to American I get
emails like every [ __ ] five minutes
yeah the airline Caribbean like do you
have all your documents in order and
it's like I just need to I don't even
like just yeah I just need the
vaccinating passport that's literally it
would stop spamming me this [ __ ] yeah
because it feels like life is moving
fast lost again you know like I I
because it was so weird right because I
remember moving to my new house right
and I remember signing at like a
two-year contract because I was like I
remember the first place that we moved
to the two years felt like an eternity
oh right oh yeah holy [ __ ] because we
always used to like live really close
together and those two years felt like
it lasted forever so I I yeah so I moved
to this new place thinking two years
that's gonna be forever because it felt
like forever in my last place right and
like my two-year contract is like
renewing within like six seven months
now yeah and I'm like what the [ __ ] I've
barely stayed at my place what yeah
and and I already got to think about
like renewing the contract and all and
all this type of stuff I was like this
like the time even though like I spent
almost the same amount of time in this
new place as I have in the old place it
doesn't feel proportional at all you
know we're also just getting older I
think it's true like that whole thing of
like you know when you were a kid I
remember like you know your your parents
or your grandma being like Oh man it's
already been a year Iris still
remembered 10 years ago and as a kid
you're like the [ __ ] you talking about
like this year has been like a quarter
of my life yeah like it's been so
[ __ ] long but now it's like I was
like Finding Nemo was yesterday right
yeah yeah he's like yeah
the 90s were 10 years ago right and then
you just like nope it's not it's 20
years ago and it's like oh [ __ ] because
like it's probably a mixture of the
pandemic and also the fact that we are
like you know gradually getting older
that like this year just [ __ ] like
went by like that for me because like
just thinking like you know some some of
these like episodes that we were doing
with some of the LA guests was like six
months ago yeah I'm just like that was
not six months ago [ __ ] that was [ __ ]
that wasn't actually no five months that
was five months oh my God that feels
like five years ago because we've done
so much [ __ ] in between ax was six
months ago holy [ __ ] isn't that [ __ ]
yeah even when I do nothing though I
find that time goes by even faster
because then I because then I I look
back and I realize oh what did I do I
didn't do that much and then it feels
like instead of like I have all these
individual events to remember it's like
I just have this small Gap that's like
squished where I was like I was playing
TFT
I'm like that that was just one month of
TFT wow that was that also happened to
perform everything what's the saying
again it's like there are some weeks
where decades happen but there are some
decades where weeks happened or
something yeah what was that from I
forgot what it was
serious I've heard that a bunch I don't
know [ __ ] some leader said that I think
it might have been a bad thing
no it was like a [ __ ] Russian leader
Google it Google it yeah not a bad
leader I think I also [ __ ] it up I
said it the other way around
there are some decades where weeks
happen but there's some weeks ridiculous
happen yeah is that is the correct term
yeah who said it who said that Vladimir
I don't know
what
are you keeping a list of cool cool
yeah every time I hear your name is
Vladimir I'm like are you a cool one
yeah no but like no but I I feel like
that saying is especially true for
especially for this year for me because
it's just like you think back to it like
you know even just the stuff that we do
for trash taste was just like insane you
know especially compared to the first
two years because we [ __ ] weren't
doing anything during the first two
years yeah yeah here in the office just
talking about exactly this year of trash
tastes felt weird because instead of
filming consistently like on a week-week
basis it feels like we've we had like
we've had like one or two months of like
intense intense intense trash Chase
films I see these boys every day and
then we'll have just have a month of
just like traveling and doing other
things and then we come back and we're
like [ __ ] we need to catch up again yeah
film 10 episodes in like the grand old
star boy yeah I mean uh I know the
audience sometimes complains like oh
they were backlogged too much and it's
like well it's obviously it's not ideal
and I think we we don't like it
sometimes we have to record so many
episodes back to back but it's either
like maybe you get an episode that isn't
as exciting as the previous one but you
get one every week yeah I mean we
prioritize that like you get an episode
every single week no matter where you
are we pride ourselves in the fact that
we're like 130 episodes in and we still
haven't missed a week no no we still
haven't missed the week and it's all
been in person like yeah like set out to
be so we've had to like intensely
schedule around that with how busy this
year has been